I find it despicable Despicable that in
a state where so many people have the
same experience Rhonda santis is using
this right now as a political stunt this
talk of a lawsuit uh really to me sounds
like election year political theater the
media is making this a big deal just
because it comes from a wealthy City
like Martha's Vineyard when hardly no
conversations being had of Tucson
Arizona El Paso Brownsville Harlingen I
don't know how you as a Mexican-American
and I don't know how you can with a
straight face say that what the governor
was simply offering was Transportation
please I actually spend a lot of time in
our Southern border and I invite you to
come down and celebrate National
understanding Heritage months down there
you'll probably see all of the Hispanic
heritage celebrated there uh and so
that's why I'm saying that what we're
seeing in our in our Southern border is
lack of attention
so the guy that just schooled Navarro's
joining us Abraham Enriquez is the
founder and president of bienvenido U.S
and he joins me now so you think she's
going to take you up on a little border
visit
you know Jesse uh Progressive activists
are very inconsistent and as you
mentioned no one sued Barack Obama in
2008 when he was flying migrants all
across the country no one sued Biden
when he in the middle of the night was
flying migrants across the country as
well but listen I think what my major
issue with national media is is that
when it comes to Hispanic issues there
token Hispanic leaders or voices are
these latinx c-list uh social climbers
like Anna Navarro who claimed to be
Republican just so that she can get on
TV and stand on the graves of dead
migrants just so she can attack real
conservatives real Republicans like
Governor DeSantis and you and I know
Jesse that in today's day to be a
conservative to be an American it means
to stand on conviction and to call
things out when they're not right and
right now we currently have a sitting
president that refuses refuses to
acknowledge and even visit the border
and his borders are that flat out lies
to the American people and says that our
borders are secure every life that was
lost that has been lost making their way
to our Southern border every woman
unaccompanied minor that has been taking
advantage of by the cartels or the
coyotes every family member that has
lost a loved one because of a fentanyl
overdose of the drugs that are pouring
into our Southern from from our Southern
border those lives are on the hands of
Joe Biden and any lawmaker that refuses
to stand on conviction and call out the
crisis that we have currently on our
border yeah you're right about that I
mean the best way to get on television
is to say you're Republican and go on
and attack Republicans have you seen any
media down there besides our border
Ducey uh our very own stupid son of a
[ __ ] with the slicked back hair they
hate him because he's the only one
reporting On the Border do you see
anybody besides bill malusion down there
absolutely not you know I spend a lot of
time in South Texas and I think what's
really important in June of this year
the special election where congresswoman
Mayra Flores became the first Mexican
born congresswoman in U.S history
flipped a seat that was held by
democrats for over a hundred years uh
that kind of foreshadows the uh
anticipation and really the frustration
that Latinos in South Texas have where
there's no coverage where there's no
attention being placed on the crisis
that's being brought on to these
communities uh in our Southern borders
in these Southern communities in South
Texas yeah but they're just going to
call her an extreme Maga Mexican America
that's what you get you're just gonna
get smeared all right thank you so much
good reporting and way to give it to
Anna
thank you Jesse good evening
hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now